a bunch of people asked me whether if  instead of putting a hair in front of  this laser beam if I put a paper with a  tiny little hole in it  um whether you would get a  three-dimensional pattern like a  circular one  I think so but I'm not sure so let's  find out oh my God this looks  incredible  it's like very 3D unlike the double slit  and the more you look the more of these  interference lines that you can see  they're much less distinct but there are  tons of them  here's the pattern look at that you can  see these contraceentric circles pretty  clearly  but there's also a lot of these like  strange defects I don't know if they're  meant to be there or not I I suspect not  and I suspect it's because I didn't make  a perfect circle  but oh my God this is so cool